- [Voiceover] If x is the
median of the seven numbers
listed above, which of the following
could be the value of x?
So the median means that if we were to put
these in order, x would
be the middle number.
We have seven numbers,
so it would actually be
the exact middle number.
If we had an even number, then it would be
the middle two averaged.
So let's think about this.
Let's order this and let's put x
in the middle of that order.
So the smallest number here is three,
then we go to four, then the next one,
let's see, we go to 10.
So those would be the three numbers
that are less than x.
Then we go to x, and now we go to
the three numbers that are greater than x.
So then we go to 15, then we go to 18,
and then we go to 21.
So we've now put them all in order.
I knew I could put x here
because x is the median.
When you put it in order,
it's the middle number.
Notice there's three
numbers larger than it,
three numbers less than it.
So I've put x in the middle,
and so x has to be some number
between 10 and 15,
and it could be 10 or 15.
But let's see the choices.
Which of these choices
are between 10 and 15?
Well five's not, eight's not, nine's not,
14 is, we're done.
16 is not, it's larger than 15,
so we're done.
X could be 14, it could also be 13,
it could be 11, it could even be 10,
it could be 15, but out
of all of the choices,
14 is the only one that
meets our constraints.